a reddit user has posted details about
an early release they received of the
edge magazine issued 3 100 the feature
cover story for this issue was all about
destiny to the each team that were
visiting Bungie were able to play
through the entirety of the campaign
missions and the overall impression was
that there was lots to do and a lot more
to find the article goes on to talk
about the energy weapons and how the
beta did not contain the final
implementation of how they work against
AI when using an elemental weapon
against enemy AI with elemental shields
when the shield has been shot down it'll
explode causing an area of effect damage
so grouped AI will be particularly
vulnerable however the first thing that
came to mind for me was whether this
will be an awesome new way to be able to
kill your teammates nightfalls now have
a slightly different structure varying
by strike each will now have the time
limit so instead of sitting back slowly
moving forward one enemy at a time
you'll have to have a well coordinated
team this is similar to the bounty that
needed the nightfall to be completed in
under 30 minutes in order to obtain that
icebreaker except in the example the
article gives it was as low as 13
minutes it's been revealed that there
are over 80 PvE missions and activities
that will be included in the game next
month each mission is substantial and
length challenge story and reward anyone
who remembers the release of destiny run
will see that this is huge
definitely what the community needs to
hear right now in fact they go on to say
that there is so much new content that
at one point in development they
realized they had more content than
progression this was obviously flexed
early on there were a few other things
revealed to the edge team during the
visit that Bungie is asking to keep out
of the article for now to leave some
surprises for the community one of these
things was to do with a hunter class
reviewers are quite happy with whatever
it has changed for at
which is good news as the hunters have
felt quite underwhelming in the beta
supers of grenades were also mentioned
they confirmed that they recharged much
faster than the beta but also in order
to charge new faster aggressive players
encouraged the example they give is a
walk exotic chess piece that lets you
hover in the air where kills what
hovering will quickly recharge your
grenades
this news has actually brought back some
of the excitement for me and it couldn't
come at a better time there's a little
over three weeks until release the ngn
team will be keeping a close eye on us
to see if anything else comes out of
this article of the next few days anyway
thanks for watching
[Music]
you